ja Freunde wir sind wir Bologna hier
vorne wo die Herrschaften gerade
reingegangen sind gibt es die angeblich
beste Bolognese der Welt und es sieht so
unscheinbar aus da lukas war vor einiger
Zeit auch hier wir haben uns gar nicht
abgesprochen wusste dass ich hier sein
würde habe das geplant deshalb falls
euch seine Perspektive interessiert
verlinke ich euch sein Video auch mal
wir gucken jetzt ob wir eine Bolognese
kriegen guckt euch das mal an ich glaube
ich habe selten so oft nicht lange
gelesen an irgendeinem Restaurant
Eingang das wäre was heißt heißen wir
dürfen Film kommt rein
[Musik]
eine Sache ich wäre hier niemals
reingekommen wenn ich nicht wüsste dass
es so besonders ist der Brummi der bei
mir im Team arbeitet hat hier in Bologna
ein Austauschjahr gemacht und meinte wir
müssen hierher kommen ich habe natürlich
auch schon viel davon gehört aber hier
gibt es scheinbar das beste rague
Bolognese ich guck mal was hier so steht
vielleicht kann ich euch ja noch mehr
erzählen also frische hausgemachte
67-jähriges Jubiläum feiert dieses
Restaurant auch hier kann man schon sich
denken dass die Qualität dafür spricht
dass sie sich so lange gehalten hat ja
aber ich meine auf der Karte muss ich
nicht lange suchen ich will eigentlich
am allerliebsten Bolognese hier bei den
primitiv in Italien klassischerweise
Antipasto prima und Sekunde also quasi
Vorspeise Pasta und dann erst die
Hauptstadt
die Gina das heißt so viel wie die
mythischen die sagenumwobenen Taille mit
dem Ragout von gigina und die Gina heißt
das Restaurant hier mit anderen Worten
die müssen richtig gut sein die werde
ich bestellen 13 € für die Pasta ist
glaube ich schon etwas teuer in Italien
aber für einen Gericht das so berühmt
ist finde ich schon echt fair ich glaube
wir halten es tatsächlich komplett
simpel wir stellen einfach nur die
Tagliatelle mit Bolognese überzeugen uns
von der Qualität weil ich habe gerade
gesehen lukas hat sein Video genannt die
leckerste Bolognese meines Lebens bin
ich gespannt ob die wirklich so gut ist
und vor allem was das Geheimnis ist
vielleicht dürfen wir in die Küche
vielleicht können wir mal nachfragen ob
uns jemand erklären kann was das Ganze
so besonders macht
sehr
guter Letzt
manno.de
[Musik]
love
die ingredientes
okay
[Musik]
wow die waren wirklich transparent ich
habe jetzt gesehen wie die vielleicht
beste Bolognese der Welt zubereitet wird
und es ist ehrlich gesagt einfacher als
gedacht weil wie so oft in den
italienischen Küche entscheiden die
Zutaten sie haben frische Pasta nur zwei
drei Minuten kocht sie haben das Ragout
in dem Rindfleisch ist und kein Schweine
Hack sondern es hat schon das sieht ja
wurst kennt man aus Italien häufig mit
Fenchel hat so einen eine gewisse
Tätigkeit und ist im Prinzip auch eine
Art Schweine Hack aber mit Gewürzen
schon ganz besonders bei ihm sie packen
die Pasta auf den Teller mischen Sie mit
ein bisschen Öl vom Ragout so dass es
nicht aneinander klebt und packen dann
oben drauf das fein gar nicht so wie man
es vielleicht bei uns kennt mit viel
viel viel Tomate so bei uns ist ja
teilweise Bolognese mit Tomatensoße hier
ist ein Ragout wirklich eine Fleischsoße
im Prinzip meine Erwartungen könnten
kaum höher sein und ich lasse mich gerne
überraschen weil es sieht nicht aus als
wäre es so außergewöhnlich also es sieht
schon irgendwie ein bisschen ich will
nicht sagen unspektakulär was sieht sehr
simpel aus und geschmacklich muss es mir
jetzt wahrscheinlich komplett den Kopf
verdrehen deshalb gucken wir mal was uns
erwartet kleiner Gruß aus der Küche
einmal so ein frittiertes bolognesisches
interessiert
ein bisschen wie so ein Shui Börek ich
glaube wenn ihr das verstehen würden
wenn du mich rauswerfen
sehr lecker das hier drüben ist so ein
gemüseei Stich
das überträgt sehr gut was man auch
sieht hier es ist schon es ist jetzt
kein mit Michel aus Stern prämiert das
Restaurant ist auch eine Art und Weise
elegant aber trotzdem sehr down also es
hat so einen sondern alten Schaden
irgendwie weil 67 Jahre sind sie schon
hier das merkt man aber die sind würde
voll geil Alter würde ich sagen also
keine Pralinen mit Rindfleisch bisschen
trocken aber auf deiner Kamera
wir sind eh nur für eine Sache hier und
das ist das war gut gerade gar nicht
sehen ich weiß es auch deshalb sehen
wir haben einmal
das heißt püriert mit ein bisschen Käse
drin und Honigmelone mit Schinken wie
schmeckt ohne Melone mit Parmaschinken
ja sehr lecker ich will auf jeden Fall
nicht zu viele Essen jetzt bevor die
Bolognese kommt obwohl ich sehr viel
Pasta gegessen habe die letzten Tage
freue ich mich sehr darauf ich probiere
jetzt noch einmal diese Oma von
Mozzarella
ganz interessant diesen intensiven
Mortadella Geschmack in der anderen Form
zu bekommen so einfach nicht als
Mortadella Wurst man merkt auf jeden
Fall dass Sie hier Ahnung von gutem
Essen haben aber ich glaube das wird ab
dem ersten Moment klar jetzt gibt es
endlich Bolognese wir haben gerade
herausgefunden dass keine frische Tomate
oder auch keine gehackte Tomate drin ist
sondern nur ein bisschen Tomatenmark bei
uns in Deutschland ist ja immer viel mit
Flüssigkeit viel Tomaten sogar ein
bisschen Wasser drauf und so weiter und
so fort hier ist das Ganze wirklich eine
Fleischsoße so wie es ursprünglich auch
gedacht ist hier haben wir sie jetzt
also die Tagliatelle mit Ragout alla
Bolognese
wirklich etwas Besonderes es kann so
einfach sein manchmal weil wenn man sich
das anschaut denkt man sich
sieht cool aus ja wir haben noch ein
bisschen erklärt bekommen
mit dem schneiden Sie das Ganze ganz
wichtig dass man das ganze vermengt für
mindestens eine Minute muss man das
ganze verwenden
und dann ergibt sich auch langsam das
altbekannte Bild auf dem Teller was man
kennt von so einer schönen Bolognese das
besonders die einzelnen Fleischstückchen
wirklich ein bisschen größer sind als
wir das vielleicht kennen
ist nicht so groß weil man in Italien
wie gesagt eigentlich danach noch was
weiteres ist aber wir haben jetzt auch
nicht so gigantischen Hunger hatte die
kleine Vorspeise gerade ich denke so
haben wir es ganz
automatisch an jetzt kommt der große
Moment
also
das Ragout
das war gut zerfällt beim Kauen man muss
es fast gar nicht kauen das ist so
unfassbar weich und sanft ich weiß nicht
ob das etwas ist was ihr da draußen
vielleicht auch kennt aber meine Oma hat
früher manchmal Haschisch gemacht ich
glaube das ist irgendwie eine hessische
Aussprache von dem französischen Wort
für gehacktes was auch so eine
fleischlastige Soße war das erinnert
mich ein bisschen daran man hat gar
nicht dieses starke tomatiges sondern
hat viel mehr so einen ja intensiven
Fleischgeschmack
aber trotzdem trifft das zu 100% diese
Bolognese Note die ich auch in meinem
Kopf habe die ich auch so sehr liebe
Bolognese ist eine meiner
lieblings-sorten durch das durchmischen
ist auch alles schön mit Soße bedeckt
und ich muss wirklich sagen dass das
eine verdammt gute Pasta ist
auf der biste die Nudeln haben
[Musik]
es ist wirklich so einfach wie es klingt
das macht es so gut ich probiere noch
mal nur das man schmeckt schon auf jeden
Fall ein bisschen die Salsiccia raus
etwas was ich sehr gerne mag alles von
allem auf eine Art und Weise definitiv
eine andere Bolognese als ihr sie zu
Hause vielleicht kennt und es
unglaublich gut es ist auf jeden Fall
eine der besten Bolognesen die ich je
gegessen habe aber meine Mama macht auch
eine ziemlich gute also Mama wenn du das
siehst
ich habe dich nicht vergessen
können die ganze Zeit so Leute Philipp
probiert jetzt auch der war gerade so
nett mich zu filmen ich bin gespannt was
du sagst
[Musik]
super anders aber besonders
also wirklich einfach eine andere
Erfahrung unglaublich gut und vielleicht
einfach nicht zum direkten Vergleich mit
der deutschen Bolognese gemacht es ist
im Prinzip ein anderes Produkt dass wir
da so ein bisschen auseinander genommen
haben genauso wie man Pizza schlecht
vergleichen kann mit Pizza Roman also
mit so einer dünnen römischen Pizza es
ist einfach was anderes aber ich glaube
in der Kategorie Bolognese aus Bologna
oder ursprüngliche Bolognese ist das
hier zehn und wahrscheinlich auch eine
verdiente Nummer eins